Matthew Perry hoped that his "Friends" legacy
wouldn't be the main thing people remembered
about him, and his final interviews hold some
haunting insights into why that was the case.
People around the world were shocked and
heartbroken to learn that "Friends" star
Matthew Perry had died at the age of 54 on
Saturday, October 28. In the days since,
social media has been flooded with touching
tributes to Perry, some of which have been
written by his colleagues and those who knew him,
others of which have been written simply by fans
of his work. What's been truly incredible,
though, is that Perry's iconic performance
as Chandler Bing on "Friends" hasn't been the
main focus of many of the tributes to him.
Instead, many have gone out of their way
to acknowledge his real-life struggles
with addiction and honor how candidly
he spoke about his life in his final
years. People have partly been able
to do so because of the interviews
that Perry gave during the 2022 press
tour for his memoir, "Friends, Lovers,
and the Big Terrible Thing." While promoting that
book, Perry spoke with astonishing frankness and
bravery about his difficult journey toward
sobriety, reflecting on the ups and downs of
his life and offering advice to anyone else
who might have ever felt lost or hopeless.
Matthew Perry's press tour for "Friends, Lovers,
and the Big Terrible Thing" was defined by the
actor's unflinching honesty. In a sit-down he
did for Macmillan imprint Flatiron Books to
promote his memoir, he got especially candid
about his beliefs that positive change can come
to anyone, regardless of their circumstances.
"There's a famous kind of line that people don't
change. I happen to know that people
do change and I see that every day."
The moving, contemplative candor
of that interview was present in
many of the final public comments
that Perry made prior to his death.
In an interview with People, Perry
explained why he hoped to use his
sobriety as an avenue to help anyone who might
be struggling with the same issues he did,
and why he waited as long as he did, saying:
"I had to wait until I was pretty
safely sober — and away from the
active disease of alcoholism and addiction
— to write it all down. The main thing was,
I was pretty certain that it would help people."
The actor brought not only real
frankness to his later years but
also a level of hard-fought
wisdom that made the weight
of his struggles just as apparent as the
impressiveness of his personal victories.
During an appearance on "Real Time with Bill
Maher," Perry further reflected on his life.
"Reality is an acquired taste. That's what
I believe. I have had a great deal of time,
a great deal of problems acquiring it."
It takes real courage for someone as
well-known as Perry to be as frank about
his personal struggles as the actor was in many
of his last interviews. The former "Friends"
star even went so far as to admit that he'd
come to view his personal highs more fondly
than any of his professional accomplishments. He
didn't expect that to ever be the case, either.
In what may have been Perry's final interview,
he recalled during a December 2022 appearance
on "The Jennifer Hudson Show" that as
a young man, he was driven by fame.
"I said, 'God, you can do anything you
want to me, just please make me famous.'"
He went on to say:
"About three weeks later, I got 'Friends,'
but God did not forget the other part and
gave me a lot of tough stuff in my
life. That's how I realized that the
outside stuff doesn't really matter.
Being famous doesn't really matter."
In the wake of that powerful realization, Perry
revealed that he didn't want anyone to remember
him best as an actor, but as a survivor and ally
to others who have struggled with addiction.
He had also said that during yet another candid
conversation in November 2022
on "Q with Tom Power," saying:
"The best thing about me, bar none, is
if somebody comes up to me and says,
'I can't stop drinking. Can you help me?'
I can say, 'Yes,' and follow up and do it."
"When I die, I don't want 'Friends' to be the
first thing that's mentioned. I want that to
be the first thing that's mentioned, and I'm
going to live the rest of my life proving that."
These are heartbreaking words to hear now,
but it looks like Perry built exactly
the legacy for himself that he wanted.
If you or anyone you know needs
help with addiction issues,
help is available. Visit the Substance Abuse
and Mental Health Services Administration
website or contact SAMHSA's National
Helpline at 1-800-662-HELP (4357).